Over 2000 years ago Euclid showed every number has exactly one prime factorization, which we can think of as a secret key.
It turns out that prime factorization is a fundamentally hard problem.
Let's clarify, what we mean by easy and hard, by introducing what's called time complexity.
We've all multiplied numbers before and each of us has our own rules for doing so in order to speed things up.
If we program a computer to multiply numbers, it can do so much faster than any human can.
Here's a graph that shows the time required for a computer to multiply two numbers.
And of course the time required to find the answer increases as the numbers get larger.
Notice that the computation time stays well under one second, even with fairly large numbers.
Therefore it is easy to perform. Now compare this to prime factorization.
If someone told you to find the prime factorization of 589, you'll notice the problem feels harder.
No matter what your strategy, it'll require some trial and error until you find a number, which evenly divides 589.
After some struggle you'll find 19x31 is the prime factorization.
If you were told to find the prime factorization of 437,231, you'd probably give up and get a computer to help you.
This works fine for small numbers, but if we try to factor larger and larger numbers there is a runaway effect.
The time needed to perform the calculations increases rapidly as there are more steps involved.
As the numbers grow the computer needs minutes, then hours,
and eventually it'll require hundreds or thousands of years to factor huge numbers.
We therefore say it is a hard problem, due to this growth rate of time needed to solve it.
So factorization is what Cocks used to build the trap door solution.
Step 1: Imagine Alice randomly generated a prime number over 150 digits long, call this P1.
Then a second random prime number roughly the same size, call this P2.
She then multiplies these 2 primes together to get a composite number N, which is over 300 digits long.
This multiplication step will take less than a second, you could even do it in the web browser.
Then she takes the factorization of N, P1xP2, and hides it.
Now, if she gave N to anyone else, they'd have to have a computer running for years to find the solution.
Step 2: Cocks needed to find a function which depends on knowing the factorization of N.
For this he looked back to work done in 1760 by Swiss mathematician Leonard Euler.